i was actually talking earlier about uh
this mother who doesn't want her
daughter to dress in black for her
wedding yeah and that i empathize with
her because my daughter wanted like a
death-themed birthday party and i was
like i can't scare the other parents and
then the invitation is that
um and
she's my girl
okay
i had a birthday party like that too
okay so tell me about this birthday
party because it sounds like actually
like maybe something we could all adapt
i don't know it sounds so cool what was
it so when i turned 40 i had a wake for
my youth
so yeah i had skull and crossbones and
people were making eulogies that were
silly and you know tongue-in-cheek and
funny and it was like ah let's bury that
part of my life and
start anew i've never heard of anyone
doing that and i feel like that is a
trend that could pick up steam yeah it
was fun it was really really fun um okay
well i'm into that and it is your
birthday actually right now right
april late
spring time
i wish for all of your wishes to come
true oh thanks honey okay so uh
okay i usually have this like in my head
but because i wasn't prepared um i uh we
were both rebellious teenagers yes oh
what's the craziest thing you ever did i
can think of a lot i mean there are a
lot but what are crazy enough to talk
about here um
me and my friend got arrested
shoplifting and so i went to the police
station all that stuff
waited for them and then when i had to
go back
the judge or i don't even know who this
person was mediator or something anyway
whoever he was he said will you ever do
this again and i said no but he's like
okay i believe you you know i'm going to
let you off on a warning and i said no
no i think i should be punished i don't
think i should just be let off like that
and he was like okay
okay
how about this for punishment you go to
therapy until you think you're done and
i was like
okay that sounds good
i'll go to therapy
do is the therapy good or was it like
well i love therapy but i kept falling
asleep in therapy
you fall asleep on the set you fall
inside
i like that you're like no i would like
the full extent of the punishment yeah
okay you are obviously in um severance
which is on apple tv plus right now
and this just in hot off the wire it's
been picked up for season two
yeah
that show
is so
avant-garde cool weird interesting um
it's so wild yeah it's really
a very interesting tone it's about this
lumen industries
and certain people that work there uh
decide to go through this procedure
called severance where they
they separate a part of their brain so
their work
their part of them that goes to work
doesn't remember their home life and the
part of them that's at home doesn't
remember their work life
and i play this upper management woman
um
who's sort of overseeing
this department it's such it just begs
such a rich
wild impossible but like i don't know
what's impossible anymore in the world
everything yeah maybe is possible and
yeah it is just such a ride of a show on
congratulations on
thank you don't ever get suffered
no um we have a clip here actually uh
will you please roll that for us
or were you sniffing around other
departments while your department falls
woefully below quarter
she almost died
it's not your job to play nursemaid to
every new refiner
okay so what is my job
are you really asking me that
yeah
what is it we actually do here
we serve care you child
the entire season of severance is
available on apple tv plus right now oh
i love you so much
[Music]
you